gun violence in the u.s. kills thousands
of people every year and so far this
year more than 6800 Americans have died
in shooting incidents according to gun
violence archives that includes at least
twenty eight since yesterday think about
that for a second this morning we're
going to take a closer look at a group
of black mothers who have lost a child
to gun violence or alleged police
brutality they want to go from grieving
to governing to make a big change mark
Strauss II spoke with two members of the
mothers of the movement and joins us at
the table to discuss they belong to a
club nobody wants to be in Marg know you
know because the price of admission is
really almost unbearable we can all
agree on that yes yes as parents I mean
the price is that you have to lose a
child violently but now there's a
movement within the movement with
congresswoman lucy macbeth it's clear
public service began with private
anguish jordan davis her 17 year old son
was gunned down outside a Florida
convenience store in 2012 a car full of
kids playing loud music made Michael
Dunn angry he fired inside it
killing Davis done got life behind bars
for murder and Macbeth forgave when this
former Delta flight attendant ran for
Congress few people expected her to win
Georgia's 6th district suburban Atlanta
is majority white wealthy and Republican
but she hosted the incumbent how much
did Jordan's death Drive your decision
to run for office Jordan's death had
everything to do with me running for
office
my mother's mission here is just
basically to take all of that concern
and support and nurturing that I would
still be doing for my son I've just
challenged channeling it to the people
that I live among every single day
Sybrina Fulton understands but
motivation I did not want this spotlight
at the 2016 Democratic National
Convention
Fulton joined a stage of mothers whose
children were slain I'm here today for
my son Trayvon Martin who is in heaven
seventeen-year-old Trayvon Martin was
unarmed when Crimewatch volunteer George
Zimmerman fatally shot him in 2012
Fulton's grief turned to activism and
now a campaign for a seat on the Miami
Dade County Commission I was like
frustrated was seeing the same things
happening and me dependent on other
people to make change so I had to be a
part of that change
lucy macbeth when she ran in one was her
success and inspiration to you
definitely it left an impact and
inspired me of course there are several
other people that ran for office that I
saw you know and it inspired me you
can't help but be empowered and inspired
by seeing somebody that had the same
tragedy that that I have and managed to
move on near st. Louis Lesley McSpadden
lost his son a police officer killed 18
year old Michael Brown his death sparked
the Ferguson riots earlier this year
McSpadden ran for City Council and lost
why are so many mothers of young black
men who were shot and killed running for
office we recognize if we don't stand up
and champion for our communities more
people within our communities continue
to die disproportionately I just think
that people are looking for a way to be
able to walk out their hurt and their
pain and their anguish and do something
for the good of others with it it's been
almost seven years and listening but
both told me she still gets up every day
worrying about how to keep her son
Jordans safe she'll never get over
losing him but she believes making a
change will help her get past it or or a
separate Fulton told me yeah nothing
could be worse than losing a child and
nothing got better no we had we've had
Sabrina at the table a couple of times
we've done interviews with her and it's
a type of thing you can't even imagine
this kind of pain
but talk about channeling your pain into
a purpose yeah it seems like they can
and will make a difference certainly
hope to make it everything I think it's
something that all of us can relate to
as parents means yes grown parents or
infants I mean it's just losing God is
just so unthinkable it's it said that
it's taken this to pull them into the
political system but I think it's very
important that they're in it you know
from grieving to governing that's the
phrasing stage yep thank you right mark
thank you